vcli le problème chinois voilà
l'obsession des états unis depuis
quelques années alors que les relations
se crispent un peu plus chaque jour
entre pékin et washington
le premier tête à tête de leur bail
donne entre les deux pays s'est tenue en
alaska le 19 mars dans une atmosphère
glaciale
non ce n'est pas une surprise lorsque
nous avons soulevé ces questions de
façon claire et directe
nous avons reçu une réponse défensive la
partie américaine ne devrait pas
sous-estimer la détermination de la
chine à sauvegarder sa souveraineté
nationale
sa sécurité et ses intérêts en matière
de développement ni sous-estimer la
volonté du peuple chinois de conserver
sa dignité nationale ainsi que ses
droits et intérêts légitimes
cyberattaques situation au xinjiang
taiwan hong kong
joe biden accusent la chine de menacer
la stabilité de l'ordre international
avec cette ambition prêtée à pékin
celle de remplacer les etats-unis en
tant que puissance dominante dans la
région indo pacifique et de prendre un
rôle plus important sur la scène
internationale
côté chinois il s'agit davantage de
remettre en question le leadership
mondial des etats-unis
la grande majorité des pays du monde ne
considère pas les états unis comme la
communauté internationale les valeurs
américaines comme les valeurs
internationales et la voix de l'amérique
comme l'opinion mondiale et ils ne
reconnaissent certainement pas les
règles établies par quelques pays comme
étant les règles internationales
de son côté joe biden souhaite réparer
ce qu'il considère comme les erreurs de
son prédécesseur donald trump l'ancien
président s'était retiré de l'accord de
partenariat transpacifique alliance à
même de faire rempart contre l' empire
chinois dans la zone australie inde
japon corée du sud les états unis
tentent désormais de s'assurer des
partenaires précieux dans cette partie
du globe
cependant certains de leurs alliés
d'asie ou d'ailleurs ne veulent pas
d'une confrontation avec la chine je
souhaiterais vivement éviter la
formation de blocs
je ne pense pas que cela rendrait
justice à de nombreuses sociétés
si nous disions que ce sont les états
unis d'un côté la chine de l'autre et si
nous faisions bloc autour de l'un des
deux selon moi
ce n'est pas la façon dont les choses
doivent se faire avec sa nouvelle route
de la soie
la chine a octroyé des prêts pour des
investissements dans toute l'afrique
l'asie et l'amérique latine
en échange du soutien de ces différents
pays la course aux investissements
internationaux pour joe biden il s'agit
aussi de rouvrir de larges avenues à l'
influence américaine
nous devons nous mettre au niveau ils
investissent des milliards de dollars
pour s'occuper d'un éventail de
questions liées au transport à
l'environnement et plein d'autres choses
nous devons nous mettre au niveau si les
deux grandes puissances ont souvent
frôlé la confrontation directe ces
derniers temps l'interdépendance demeure
élevé entre elles en attendant c'est la
diplomatie du vaccin qui redessinent les
lignes des partenariats internationaux
pour l'heure aucune confrontation
sino-américaines de ce côté là